je me sens sans
devant la fin de mon enfant allez-vous
voir sur l'univers
je vais refaire
aire alors vous avez quel âge
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui 33 ans 33 ans
est-ce que malgré tout enfin il y a pas
toujours ce problème qui est que on vous
a connu pour un énorme single avec
Johnny on vous a aimé à 12 ans petite
mignonne et forcément on a peut-être les
fans n'ont pas envie d'avoir une fille
de 33 ans toujours mignonne mais est-ce
que c'est pas vous ramenez pas beaucoup
plus aujourd'hui parce que il y a eu ce
début pas du tout au contraire les gens
se souviennent de moi et c'est ça qui
est incroyable on me reconnaît toujours
dans la rue partout où je vais les gens
me disent en revanche les gens
m'appellent clémence et Johnny on
m'appelle pas Clémenceau donc ça c'est
rigolo et les gens dans la rue me disant
c'est Clément c'est Johnny donc c'est
c'est une anecdote sympathique mais
quand on vient de moi c'est pas
compliqué de couper le cordon quand même
non et c'est aussi pas mal d'avoir un
cordon avec Johnny vous faites The Voice
oui on m'a contacté pour le faire et
j'avoue je me suis lancé dans l'aventure
en me disant j'adore cette émission donc